[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday November
15th
Hank today's video comes in four parts
part 1 pop quiz question for you Hank
what's the surest evidence that the US
economy is on a kind of permanent
downslope answer in his newest music
video the rapper jay-z is seen walking
through the streets of New York holding
a wad of 500 euro bills Hank even jay-z
is worried about the weakness of the
American dollar now that wouldn't really
bother me if we were talking about Lil
Jon or t-pain or somebody but we're
talking about jay-z one of the great
entrepreneurial minds of our generation
I mean Hank this is the same guy who
once noted I'm not a businessman I'm a
businessman also he has the hottest girl
in the game wearing his chain anyway
Hank this news only makes me more want
to move to Europe or possibly Australia
speaking of Australia in Australia they
have something called the inky awards
which are given out for young adult
literature and you'll never guess who
won the first international inky award
also known as the silver inky it was me
so thanks to all my readers in Australia
and also all the nerdfighters who voted
for Looking for Alaska in the inky
Awards by the way Hank do you know what
they give you for winning an inky award
a trophy and you know about my tortured
history with trophies by the way the
trophy you see in the background is when
I got in college for heading my sketch
comedy group up Hank I don't know
exactly what the trophy is going to look
like but we can only hope that it's
going to say John Green winner of the
2007 silver inky in our hearts by the
way Hank you know who lives in Australia
our secret niece and nephew Natalie and
Calvin which brings me to the next thing
this is a segment I like to call what's
going on in nerdfighteria hey check out
the crown that Natalie made me for being
the toilet paper
eating king of the world also in news
from nerdfighteria and I can hardly say
this without laughing because it is so
incredibly amazing there's a nerdfighter
who's about to have a baby and she is
considering naming that baby Hank how
awesome would that be the nerdfighter in
question has posted a list of potential
baby names on the internet and asked
people to go vote I would encourage all
nerdfighters everywhere to check out the
link in the video info and go vote
immediately for Hank thing for Venn
diagrams
god I love Venn diagrams okay first we
have nerdfighters people who like to
watch the hills on MTV and then the
intersection because of course people
who feel ashamed about watching the
hills on MTV by the way nerdfighters
this doesn't count
full communication as has been
established by previous Venn diagram
jokes then diagram number two over here
we have people who like cameo over here
we have nerdfighters lots of
intersection and then down here in the
corner we have people who like cameo but
sometimes get freaked out when she
stares directly at the camera during
Brotherhood 2.0 episodes because
sometimes I think she could kill me
without feeling any remorse and then
finally we have the gooey feeling you're
feeling when something's about to begin
the gooey feeling you feel when
something's about to end inside of
there's anxiety inside of there is
sadness and in the middle is where
awesome lives panic I look forward to
seeing more of the LA Auto Show tomorrow
I'll see you then
scavenger hunters you've already seen
the clue that's in this video